good oh my that it's working for me
did you guys hear that okay I can pick
up objects which is like the first sign
what is behind this door I'm spectating
you're not really much appreciate if you
get away from that door and the baby
that's led to blood I know that's why
I'm wondering don't just come find me
God egg next to the poison toilet room
what poison toilet room I am not even at
all joking
oh my god the boys in toilet room Oh
what's with the babies yeah come down
this hallway towards the green mist and
the boys and toilets well this is gonna
be interesting
this is gonna be awesome oh my god that
means they're gonna hide in like the
worst place I'm gonna go back to that
room that I was seeing before and oh I
just I just are the greatest name prop
homes exist whoa what there's a trap
door there because it's trap doors is
this oh my god I fell oh I didn't die oh
this is horrible I gotta go this room
it's freaking me out
kick out let me get out okay the sounds
are pretty creepy - oh okay closed
forever closed forever please iStock
what's with the fruit room yeah hey hey
you milk carton what you didn't see
anything
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
he distracted me with this terrifying
face yeah
that room does stuff to you yeah
unnatural stuff would you go no I gave
you the slip he's gone you got out of it
let's go back to the baby room I bet
he's I bet he to the other side he
wouldn't be that brings Kazon I think
he's in here no I don't know oh my god
go down the whole character chase after
him it's just really freaking hard to
[Laughter]
fitting in for us - I saw you wait I
just could never shoot you
the very beginning I threw a trash can
in the hallway I kept seeing the trash
can running around and around and I
could not do anything about it
Oh oh god this is gonna be so much fun
I'll see if this works out it was gonna
be the first one to be a bloody baby
that's what I want to know it's gonna be
the only one standing up in the group
case okay no standing babies yeah me are
you which nightmare room are you in
it's the worst nightmare room I don't
know which one is I haven't seen every
room yet it was the one with the faces
on the wall I can stand help if you need
it yeah he it's help definitely needs
help
oh yeah just stare at those faces are no
longer in no wait I go though oh my god
I lit a lamp and a baby went flying oh
my god yeah those holes are bad news huh
all right can we get a clue I'm right
next
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh yeah baby
the trapdoor yeah there's somebody ins
and outs of somebody's second way to go
oh my god oh god this door its door
before I go to bed oh you play horror
games for a living come on grow some
balls
oh I see I'm gonna get ya three seconds
guys working out in my favor
oh no he's trapped in the sticky toilet
room no I'm not you don't know that you
don't know any of that I'm checking the
room with the faces oh god my way
breathing like whether or not that would
kill me I see your body just twitching
they're the largest all right oh I don't
give the spectate mark that's so creepy
though thank you Oh Oh Marcus literally
cannot so let's reach that what is that
over there jump on the toilet or is that
impossible I think I see a room of
purgatory over in the over there even
worse in the face room where do you see
it Bob how we get there I don't know I
want to I'll kill you and then we'll
[ __ ]
why do I want to get there oh why do I
want to get there there must be a fake
wall and you can get trapped in the
purgatory maybe I don't know or maybe
you just like randomly you get plucked
and moved mr. map is disturbing
disturbing and scary I found it you
found it how did you found it Oh God
Bob are you even able to get out of
there oh I'm hiding here because I don't
know if anyone else can find it but this
is oh where is it I want to come in I
guess the only objective is right now
and I get that that door yes toward that
freaking doorman that's bad I'm okay I
know how to get out but now I'm staying
I've found a few where I can only see
several faces so oh I live with this a
little oh this is nothing
where are you guys I don't even see you
you're in a completely different room I
think like you're isolated away from all
of us yeah I kind of am like magically
isolated oh there's an upstairs it's a
too mysterious and unmarked door but all
you have to do is run into it and it
like opens with a touch I see you
upstairs person running around on a
mobile and you're really close to me
spatially but you're nowhere even
remotely close to finding the room okay
I got you you were like 10 feet away
from me okay second well yeah your ear
no it's not up there okay okay all right
all right all right all right all right
all right
copyrighted oh yeah sorry about that
forgot
is it where's the baby go oh-ho baby I'm
not looking for Yami I'm trying to find
your I'm I am are you in the baby room
are you in the blood baby I am now I
[Laughter]
knew that was gonna happen is in the
baby room yeah the door to the horrible
room of horribleness is in the babies
against the wall Yami oh god yeah I know
Yami can't see me the only place you
could have gone yes you did I am very
talented twice what's he'll into did
okay is that a word man I did you you
are smarter than I thought
thank you um I messed up and now there's
a floating Orange are you the floating
or injure I wish is there just
generically a floating orange around no
there well it wasn't but there is now
okay Janine how to find you then mmm
any last words
hello oh my gosh Oh God
goodbye age skipping around like a mwah
how did that happen orange I don't even
know
what happened I'm so confused
what happened I'm sick what Yami I told
you I was not the floating orange I just
messed up and not in maybe 100 don't
worry I'm on five HP is it this oh my
god
one thing wrong I will die this is you
right oh can we please shoot this big
floating box Thanks no no that thing
that's not the box is not a thing yeah
that's not a thing
Hey okay I saw his name for a second
whose name wanes then would it surprise
you to know that we're both in this room
at this moment yes yeah I know where the
oh wait yeah they're on the complete
wrong track No then you know wait wait
so Wade's not in that room to kill the
banana yeah yeah
you wait you use my death as a means of
escape that is genius that is genius
very well done but because it is you I
still hate you just so you know I don't
oh man I'm stuck it's not stuck there
was nothing to get stuck on no like I
can't leave now oh okay I will find wait
it's you his exact location no he's not
he's in the room again the horrifying
room the room of despair and what a
pretty terrifying room it's raining all
the rooms are terrifying I don't know
there's certain different this one you
really have to face your fears to get
over well that was pretty obvious so
it's not the one face room it's the
other face room it's one of them hey
[Laughter]
face room got to be a play no life
grow in that room all right you know I
recently till asked my brother if he
said rum the same way I do and he did
but and he never thought of it that it
was weird or anything so now he's very
self-conscious of it - Oh way to go
I'm classic nice brother yeah I am well
there's room for improvement there it's
not rum it's rum nice bedroom you got
there Tommy how do you save room room oh
we haven't made our faces we haven't
made our face and this one's almost over
oh okay what face should we make its
Pope's tend to pick Bob what should we
make you should make the face that you
make when you're eating I don't know
when you're eating sushi
that's like clearly bad but you really
want sushi oh you're trying to like
stomach it but you know that I have
orbble hard diarrhea I'm eating it first
I say all right three two one go oh I've
been doing this whole time that's just
the face that I always make when I'm
eating sushi when when the gifts are
made of that actually put sushi rolls
going into our mouths like comically
oversized it's a very complicated order
for you Tom Blair
but you I know you can do it I but I
believe they're dedicated I haven't even
been trying to look that was mine and
Bob's cunning plans wasted all right so
we're all right where I am in one of the
most horrifying spots on the entire map
oh really
I know I'm in one of the least
horrifying spots Walter said you
when you said most horrifying I know
exactly what you mean I was bringing
milk to the baby
Oh God no weird things that are just
randomly floating I thought he might
have been something else the barrels the
objects
[Laughter]
[Music]